donc là laurent vous êtes parti pour
l'entraînement là c'est ça c'est ça
c'est pas l'entraînement de l'endurance
et de la résistance à dire qu'il faut
arriver à être essoufflée et surtout
faire des petites actions plus tonique
pendant au moins deux minutes où l'on
fait monter le coeur très très vite
et là c'est du rameur voilà longtemps
que ce rêve trottait dans sa tête
participer à la mythique route du rhum
l'euro a franchi le pas cette année il a
trouvé une goélette coque tout en métal
qui fête tout juste ses 40 ans comme la
route du rhum il lui a suffi après de
convaincre ses collègues kiné qui
travaille avec lui sur les pathologies
respiratoires
partir oui mais pour une bonne cause lui
il veut se battre contre les méfaits de
la cigarette on partage vraiment ça
parce que c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé
c'est vrai qu'on a décidé ça il ya un an
et demi c'est vraiment un coup de folie
c'est vraiment un truc de dingue mais
c'était l'occasion c'était le moment il
y avait le bateau il y avait c'était le
moment où l'espace du souffle changer un
petit peu en terme d'activité et on
s'est dit c'est l'occasion met un coup
de projecteur sur les maladies
respiratoires
l'entraînement est intensif il faut être
au top physiquement mais aussi apprendre
à gérer son sommeil
l'idée c'est de savoir gérer son énergie
pendant un mois sachant qu'on va être
actif 24 heures sur 24
quasiment et donc farivar der phase de
récupération de 20 minutes toutes les
deux heures voilà pour faire une moyenne
de 4 heures 4 heures 5 heures par jour
faut apprendre à se connaître savoir les
bons moments pour faire ça et savoir
s'organiser à bord pour mettre tout ça
en place
c'est aussi important pour garder la
lucidité dans les décisions
alors laurent alterne entre
l'entraînement physique comme ici à tour
et des sorties en mer depuis lorient où
est basée la goélette là maintenant on
fait des petits run de 2 3 jours tout
seul sur le bateau
ensuite je ramène sur le ramène le
bateau au port on répare ce qu'il faut
réparer le but c'est de casser un
maximum de choses maintenant en ayant
testé le bateau un peu rudement sachant
que moi sur la traversée je vais pas du
tout un traité le bateau le but c'est
pas de tirer dessus je fais pas la
course
le bateau sera jamais prêt en fait mais
suffisamment parce que parce que c'est
comme ça en mer il faut pouvoir parer à
tout et c'est impossible
et c'est pareil pour les patients pour
les pour les gens qui veulent arrêter de
fumer c'est vraiment pareil de toute
façon c'est comme s'il était impossible
mais on va y arriver quand même et on va
le faire
les flyers sont arrivés je perds on voit
bien les deux voiles bien gonfler le
départ de la route du rhum est prévue le
4 novembre prochain depuis saint malo
ce jour-là un dispositif fera sortir de
la fumée du mat sa goélette avec sa
traversée
laurent espère entrer dans son sillage
le maximum de fumeurs et les convaincre
d'arrêter la cigarette